- With COVID, from day
one, he was always trying
to look at the data, you know?
And so, by the time
I started working,
it was a little over a year ago,
it was spring 2021 before
Delta surge started.
And Delta, it was bad.
I mean, it was bad in Florida
and everywhere in the country,
and a lot of people had
COVID and were very sick.
And during that time, you know,
Governor DeSantis, I would
see him almost every day,
and he would be
reading the studies.
He'd be reading the latest
information from Israel,
from Europe, from countries
that were ahead of us
in the Delta surge.
And he saw that, number one,
the vaccine is not stopping
transmission of the virus,
so, the mandates
made no sense at all,
and he doubled down,
like, no matter what,
every single press conference,
and we had press conferences
every day during that time,
we would get reporters
yelling in his face about,
when are you going
to do a lockdown?
When are you gonna
do a mask mandate?
What about vaccine mandates?
And he'd always just
say, no, I mean,
despite all of this pressure,
because he knew
what the data said.
(funky electronic music)
- And speaking of our governor,
I am now going to bring out, oh,
that could be the gov calling
into the show right now.
I am now gonna bring
out Governor DeSantis'
press secretary,
Christina Pushaw.
- I am not deterred
by any smear piece
from these legacy media outlets.
The only reason
they're attacking her
is 'cause she does a great job,
and she's very
effective at calling out
their lies and their
phony narratives.
And so, whenever they're
smearing somebody,
you know that person
is over the target,
and so, they're scared of that.
I would be much more concerned
with my press secretary
if the Washington Post was
writing puff pieces about her.
Then, I would think
something was wrong, so -
- Man, how good is that?
Now, make some noise
for Christina Pushaw.
(crowd cheers)
All right, Christina.
So, why don't we
just clarify it,
in case anyone from
Media Matters is here.
Are you an agent of another
government or foreign entity
sent to Florida to take
us out from the inside?
- Absolutely not.
- Oops, lets. They shut her mic.
They shut her mic.
- That was pressure, right?
No, that was Media
Matters doing that.
- Yeah.
- They don't want me here
tonight I guess, but no, no.
I'm not a agent of any
foreign government.
I don't know how I
would've been hired
by the state of Florida.
We had background checks,
you know, like, to get hired.
- Right, and this thing that
they were accusing you of,
you actually had on your
resume that you've worked
for some other people in
other countries and things.
- Absolutely.
I think the fact that
I worked in, like,
a former Soviet country
and in Eastern Europe,
that's actually what
helped me get this job,
because I know what communism
does and what it is,
and that's what we're fighting
against here, right, so?
(crowd cheers)
- So, for the people that
don't know you too well,
or only know you
through Twitter,
can you tell people a
little bit of your story?
Because it's actually
a perfect story
for someone to come here to
Florida, to defend freedom,
to defend the governor,
to defend all these
people and all that stuff.
- Yeah, sure.
So I don't know how much
detail you want me to go into,
but, like you, I'm
from Los Angeles.
I grew up in California,
so, the People's
Republic of California.
Back when I was a
kid, it wasn't as bad.
But with Gavin Newsome, I mean,
I know you guys saw
some of his latest hits.
It's gotten really, really bad.
But when I was in college,
I studied international
relations.
I was always really
into foreign policy
and international
economics, too.
So, I ended up, long
story short, working
in Eastern Europe.
I worked in the
country of Georgia.
I studied abroad in Russia,
and I learned a lot about, you
know, that part of the world,
and basically the
legacy of communism
and just how bad it was
and how the effects are
still being felt today
even though these countries
are not communist anymore.
You know, it's not something
you recover from very quickly.
So, after seeing how California,
such a beautiful state,
was destroyed by one party
rule by progressive Democrats,
long story short, that's
how I became a conservative.
Now, how I came to Florida
is a little bit of
a different story.
It was during COVID. I was
living in Washington, DC.
I was working as a
political consultant.
So, I worked on campaigns
in other countries,
but during COVID in DC,
I mean, it was miserable.
It was, the entire
city's locked down.
People in my neighborhood
are wearing masks outside.
I was running outside one day.
I got yelled at for not wearing
a mask while I was on a run.
That was probably the moment
I realized, I have to leave.
And this was also,
the worst part was,
it wasn't just the mandates
that were making people,
like, act like this.
It was that they,
genuinely, in their hearts,
they wanted to comply.
They wanted to conform.
Like, that's the mentality
of progressives these days,
unfortunately,
leftism and communism,
it's a very
conformist mentality.
And I just got depressed,
like, looking at this
all around me, DC, you know,
it's like, 95% voted for Biden.
And I just felt like,
I'm in the wrong place
after the election
of last, of 2020.
And just a lot of stuff
that happened after that,
I realized, this is
the wrong place for me.
Florida was like the bright
light in the darkness.
It was like the West Berlin
of the Cold War, right?
Like, this is where
freedom still lives.
And so, I'm like, okay, I
have to come to Florida.
I love what Governor
DeSantis is doing.
He is really standing up
against the whole, like,
biomedical security state, the
mandates, the restrictions,
the lockdowns.
Life is normal in Florida.
And so, I went for CPAC
2021, met some people
who worked with Governor
DeSantis and spoke with them,
got to know them and,
long story short,
that's how I ended
up coming to Florida
and getting this great job,
so, very blessed to be here.
- It's really remarkable
how Florida man,
the caricature of
Florida man, you know,
this guy with a
cigar in one hand
and he's wrestling an alligator
and ripping a baby out of
its head on a golf course.
And it's like, Florida
man knew something, right?
Florida man was doing it right.
I really, for all of you that
are born and bred Floridians,
holy cow, you
really, you saved us.
You really did.
So, I know people always
wanna know insider things
about the governor, and
you can't share anything
that's not to be fully shared.
But when you got here, and
you start working for him.
Now, COVID's going crazy.
It was not easy for
him to get out there
and say, hey, no, I'm not
gonna close the state.
I'm gonna let people go to work.
I'm not gonna inject
everybody, all that stuff.
Can you talk a little bit
about his thought process
and how he made decisions?
- Well, the first
thing to understand
about Governor DeSantis is that,
even though he's not a doctor
or a scientist by training,
he's a smart guy.
And he likes to read
in detail before,
like, he makes a
policy decision.
So, with COVID, from day one,
he was always trying to
look at the data, you know?
And so, by the time
I started working,
it was a little over a year ago.
It was spring 2021 before
Delta surge started,
and Delta, it was bad.
I mean, it was bad in Florida
and everywhere in the country,
and a lot of people had
COVID and were very sick.
And during that time, you
know, Governor DeSantis,
I would see him
almost every day,
and he would be
reading the studies.
He'd be reading the latest
information from Israel,
from Europe, from countries
that were ahead of us
in the Delta surge.
And he saw that, number one,
the vaccine is not stopping
transmission of the virus.
So, the mandates
made no sense at all.
And he doubled down,
like, no matter what,
every single press conference,
and we had press conferences
every day during that time,
we would get reporters
yelling in his face about,
when are you going
to do a lockdown?
When are you gonna
do a mask mandate?
What about vaccine mandates?
And he'd always just say, no.
I mean, despite all
of this pressure,
because he knew
what the data said.
And so, that's very different
from a lot of politicians.
They would look at more, like,
what the political data says.
So, like the polling data and
the focus groups and whatnot,
but he's not that
kind of a politician.
He is a leader.
That means he looks at reality,
and makes a decision
based on that.
And then, people come
along with him, right?
And so, like, with
mask mandates, even.
He knew that even with
Delta as bad as it was,
it, thank God it wasn't
affecting children severely.
So, he thought it's
more important,
I mean, he's a dad,
he has little kids.
He knows how important
it is for kids to, like,
have a normal life
and go to school
and be with their friends and
be in their routines, right?
And so, that was
one of the things
that was non-negotiable for him.
Like, schools are gonna be open
and kids are not gonna
be forced to wear a mask.
The parents can make the choice,
but kids are not
gonna be forced.
And so, he was attacked
nonstop for that.
And I, you know, I heard
him talking to people, like,
whether it was in
private or in public
at a press conference.
And he was always saying
like, look at the data.
Kids are okay.
It's going to be worse for
kids to be living in, like,
this dystopia and growing
up without seeing faces
and this and that.
So, like, now he's right.
Now, nobody wants
to remember, like,
that they criticized
him for this.
Now everyone pretends they
were on board with him
the whole time with schools
being open, with, you know,
no mask mandates and, you know,
they're trying to
memory hole it,
but we remember how many
people attacked him.
We remember that he was
really the first politician
to come out and say,
like, enough, you know,
it's going to be
up to the parents.
And now, everyone has
followed, and that's great.
We're very happy about that.
But like, somebody had to
stand up and take the heat.
And at that time, there were
polls coming out last summer
saying that most parents
wanted mask mandates.
And he said, okay, that's
because they they're afraid.
They're being sold
lies by the media.
And they're being basically
manipulated into thinking this.
And lo and behold, he was right.
He had to just make a decision
that was unpopular at the time.
And now, everyone realizes,
like, he was right.
That's what leadership
is, I think.
(crowd cheers)
- Don't you guys sort
of feel like he actually
is the president
in a way, right?
Like, in a way, if America's
gonna continue, he sort of,
he's make, exactly.
Make America Florida,
I think you mean, yeah.
Make America Florida, exactly.
Were there ever any moments
in the heat of all of it
that he almost
cracked and gave in?
Because everybody was coming
after him all the time.
- [Christina] No.
- I mean, even now,
still they're trying it.
- I think when people
come after him,
it makes him even more
resolute in what he's doing.
The more that the media attacks,
you saw the clip that you
ran right before, like,
we started talking,
the clip about me.
When I got attacked, he
said, you know, that's great.
When Dr. Ladapo, you know,
our great surgeon general,
he gets attacked.
- Yeah.
(crowd cheers)
- Thank you. He's awesome.
He gets attacked by
the media all the time.
I remember, I was with
the surgeon general
and the governor,
and we were at a Wawa somewhere
in the middle of Florida,
in Tampa Bay.
And I remember in the Tampa
Bay Times, the front page
was a story about Dr. Ladapo
and how he's an anti-vaxxer
quack and all of this nonsense.
And so, it was when he was new.
He wasn't confirmed yet
as a surgeon general.
Like, Senate still had
to do the confirmation.
So, I was a little
bit concerned.
I look at the paper,
I'm like Dr. Ladapo,
like, are you feeling okay?
You know, he just
came from California.
He's not a politician.
Being in the public eye
is kind of new to him.
So I was like, are
you feeling okay?
And he's like, yeah, as
long as the governor's okay.
And the governor said,
look, the more that people
are attacking Joe, that's
what he calls Dr. Ladapo,
the more people are
attacking Joe, the better,
because that means he's
doing something right.
- [Dave] There you go.
- And I think that's true.
- So, speaking of
doing something right,
I think most of us can agree,
we're kind of doing it
right here in Florida,
and people are living
free and all that stuff.
Is there anything that
in Florida right now
we're not doing right, or
places that the governor
or the administration
is going, oh,
we have to fix this or that?
- [Audience Member]
School choice.
(audience members shout)
- That's a great question.
Honestly -
- You didn't think I
was gonna make it easy
for you up here, did ya?
- We can always be doing better.
I think, I mean, I'm really
proud of what Florida has done,
of the example that
we are to the country.
We are a leader
in school choice,
could always do more on that,
and I believe that'll happen.
You know, there's a
lot of conservatives
come to me and say,
like, constitutional carry
is a big priority for them.
And that's something
the governor has said
that he is committed to doing
before he leaves office.
So, I believe that.
I've never heard
him say something
that he doesn't
follow through on, so,
you know, there are always
ways we could improve.
And we're always trying
to listen to people,
listen to Floridians,
and look at what's going
on in other states,
other countries that
we might be able to use
and we might be able
to replicate here.
But I do think Florida
has been a good example
for the country.
- So what else?
Yeah, you can applaud that.
Florida has been a
pretty good example.
(audience applauds)
What else do you think
that these folks can do
to help Governor DeSantis fight
this thing, to get involved?
Like, how can people,
you know, beyond voting.
We get it.
They're all gonna get
out in November and vote,
and he's gonna win something
like 90% of the vote.
There, you heard it
first, but, yeah.
What else can people
do, do you think?
- You know, but that, what
you said is really important,
'cause, like, I go to a
lot of places in Florida
with the governor.
I think he's been to all
67 counties this year.
And I go to a lot
of those places,
and people will come up and
say, like, how great he is
and how, like, they're gonna
vote for him for president.
Now I always say,
wait, wait, back up.
He's not running for president.
He's running for reelection
as the governor of the
great state of Florida.
So, you need to vote in
November, like, of this year.
So, that's what I'm always
trying to remind people.
- She almost broke some
serious news here tonight.
That was, we almost.
- Like, we don't wanna take
anything for granted, 'cause,
like you said, 90% of the vote.
I mean, that'd be great.
I think he deserves it.
He deserves a hundred
percent, but Florida,
it's always been a swing state.
I believe it's becoming
more of a red state,
thanks to Governor
DeSantis' leadership,
but we never take
anything for granted.
You know, you have to always run
like you're 10 points behind,
and that's what he's doing.
He's working hard.
And I, that's why I'm, vote
is my number one thing.
Talk to your friends,
family about it.
You know, don't take it for
granted that he's gonna win
just because his opponents
are very weak, which is true.
But like, you can't take
anything for granted, you know.
You never know
what's gonna happen.
So, I think that's
probably the main thing,
and then, get involved
at the local level.
Like, there are,
these days, I think
conservatives are realizing how
important school boards are.
It was never that big of a thing
until the last couple of years.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- I think parents
have realized, like,
how much power they have
over your family's life,
over your kids' lives,
and how much they've abused
their power in some places,
including here in Florida.
Yeah, unfortunately,
that was one that did.
- [Dave] Yep.
- And there were
others, as well.
And so, I think that's something
that we can learn from,
and that, I know a lot
of great conservatives
are running for school
board, including in Broward
and everywhere in Florida,
actually, this fall.
So, we need to replace the ones
that acted like petty
dictators, right?
And so, getting involved
locally is important.
(audience applauds)
- Well, I'm gonna bring
out our other two guests
in a moment, who are
also great Floridians,
but I just wanna say,
since we got a room
full of people here,
that you guys are just
doing an incredible job,
and you helped me
make the move here
and live a better life
here and all that stuff.
So, make some noise for
Christina, everybody.
(crowd cheers)
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.